I heard that maybe you were interested
in running for class oh I'll be the
governor of Arkansas for sure yes yes
that's the thing that's happened oh yeah
I thought about running in 2018 but
maybe 2020 to probably 2026 yeah yeah I
do believe that will be the governor in
my home city what do you want to change
how well this I grew up was very little
and my education was terrible so what I
want to do is fix impoverished places
and particular educational system to
believe if you can learn you can
actually go and achieve so that's what
that's really the core of what I want to
help but what's my focus is finding
people to come from not alive and
showing them in the way out those that I
can I'm in Los Angeles right now doing
my show in there so you be wherever you
want then you know we're technology
allows you to do whatever you want
whatever you want so yeah I will run for
governor hopefully I'm a president like
a plan of the United States yeah Bobby
bones revealing his political
aspirations to ET if you don't sit huge
goal for yourself no one else will so I
have the biggest goal what do you think
of this I'm old for it I'll run the
campaign no your citizenship there we
guard now I'm definitely a horse but
first his sights are set on winning that
Mirrorball trophy which starboard 370
pictured across the Bayard even their
Halloween themed dance for our cameras
only I know that you're doing mr.
Sandman how did you hit that
I came across this really creepy version
of the song and I kind of just fell in
love with it and I decided that it was
time for bubbie to do a whole other
character now it's time to get a little
bit for city it's Thursday so how ready
are you I mean another routine like
totally perform is ready right are you
no bruh
I don't know what the normal protocol is
but by Thursday I'm going I think I know
it in my mind but we know we're
definitely not ready we're not ready -
usually Saturday Sun Monday right now we
go on five six seven eight
I want foot what is the biggest
challenge of this dance and I'm so
confused by the whole thing it's very
strong and like sexy it's the two things
I'm not I'm still learning I was like
kicking and I kicked on the ankle so
hard yesterday okay wasn't that hard
okay kick her moderately hard which
doesn't feel good do you throw her balls
like do you want to make him strong and
sexy just picking out the challenge for
him I want to do that because I think he
hasn't in him and he just doesn't
believe it so I just want to prove so
everybody does yeah are we doing any
lips any crazy junk why don't we go I
want to see you lift her we have I do
too
if I could be honest I would but go
ahead
we have a couple of lifts in there but
at the same time lift isn't our strong
suit in this couple which we done about
that strong that's what you're saying
right now cuz I'm not that fun when you
have people like DeMarcus and Lindsay
that he can literally spin her on his
pinky finger you know what I mean she
can jump so well she's so strong that
she actually does 80% of any letter we
do anyway she's like just put your hands
there and I'll jump and I'll do it good
what Bobby and I have is an amazing
chemistry right so we're gonna be able
to play this story and these characters
really really well because it it does
have a sexiness to it two out Jim Beam
tango has a natural intimacy to it so we
don't want to lose that either
who is your guys's biggest competition
right now would you say honestly I think
it's it's like the little voice that
lives inside this head on Monday that's
what I think how big we do when we get
to practice and we
all week and we have it and we killing
it and then what happens is before the
dance starts what you people can't hear
at home is there's a click that happens
he goes and it tells you when the
music's about to start
I get so revved up didn't I go a little
fast because I'm like aah
and so he has I'm out though if you want
slow down slow down slow down stretch
slow down
how do you calm him down they just have
to keep talking to him through it that
have headphones adjust her voice and I
sleep with this in the music I sleep
with her voice my soothing wonderful
voice box tonight people obviously love
you guys what is the most a prize in
Canadian learning about charm of cars
kind of messy which I wouldn't have
expected
she's so put together I know my car
isn't her borrow you get it yeah and
it's like remove the highlighters and
band-aids and shoes and and it's the
head like make up everything is in my
car that I could possibly made for that
reason but hers is like it can't be get
in the seat like you gotta get a cup you
get a crime frontsies are dramatic so I
would say it's he needs to put
moisturizer on his hands when he does
spray tales like orange we haven't
learned how to do spray tans yet this is
this is a lot to be learned how to do
spray tans then I'm not gonna be am you
are you guys shocked at the amount of
love and fandom we have a fan well then
I read that I most of the like you could
be better body don't let join it down
that's the most about all the kind I'm
trying as hard as I can what are you
gonna stop being so tiring yourself
that's like when I die
that's probably no that's also like
working on you
therapist / dance coach Oh laughing
[Music]
[Applause]